what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
marvel studios is making a little bit of
a change a really really good change
that fans are going to be very excited
about this news means that a lot of good
things are about to happen very soon and
are going to happen in the future and
that is it looks like marvel is indeed
going to be embracing their rated r side
i know a lot of people were worried
about this with deadpool coming to the
mcu they were worried that marvel
studios and disney in particular were
going to kind of bump him down to a
pg-13 film which would be unfortunate
because that would kind of kill who
deadpool is really he's probably one of
the very few characters that really
needs to be unfiltered but it looks like
marvel studios has a plan it looks like
they're taking action right now actually
with this plan and it all starts with
the marvel netflix shows coming to
disney plus this month this is awesome
news because this means we can get some
new superhero groups and new characters
in the mcu that can all be rated r we
can have a much darker kind of grungier
side of the mcu and this will affect
some new characters but it will also
affect some characters that we already
have some of the more clean cut
characters so in this video i'll talk
about the new groups that we could
possibly get and yes we will be talking
about the midnight suns but also be
talking about how characters and groups
like these will affect the groups like
the avengers let's dive into it but of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news so like i said
this all started with the marvel netflix
series as contracts being done they are
now not on netflix anymore and they are
heading to disney plus this month
however for those of you who have
watched these series on netflix like
daredevil and the punisher you know that
they're kind of darker serious they can
be dark and they can be kind of brutal
and much more blood is shown in these
series so rather than not having these
show on disney plus and perhaps maybe
putting them on a streaming platform
like hulu which of course they own as
well they are actually making some
updates and some changes to their
parental controls on disney plus now
what they're doing is basically adding
more parental controls giving a little
bit more customization to the parents so
they can limit or filter out shows and
movies that they don't want their kids
watching now i know that this doesn't
really affect us that much we want to
watch the marvel shows but this is good
news because we were worried disney plus
wasn't really going to show anything
that was rated r like deadpool like
logan but this is the first step in
marvel studios and disney going towards
a rated r future because deadpool 3 is
right around the corner in fact ryan
reynolds said that he promises an update
soon so the timing of all of this is
kind of lining up then of course we have
moon night that is coming in it's
supposed to be violent i'm imagining
that moon knight is probably going to be
like daredevil and like the punisher the
netflix series which again the timing is
kind of perfect here the netflix series
are coming right before the release of
moon night about 15 days before and
they're updating their parental settings
so i'm guessing moon knight is going to
live up to the rumors and it is going to
be kind of violent and this is a certain
side of the mcu a more kind of adult
side that they have kind of been lacking
in of course i love everything that's
come out so far but expanding and
growing into different areas is always
good and we also have blade coming now
the original blade films were rated r
and side note ryan reynolds was actually
in blade trinity so i think it would be
hilarious that if in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness we saw blade
and then we saw ryan reynolds and people
thought he was wade wilson deadpool and
he's like what no who's that the
potential for that movie is limitless
but anyways back to blade the new blade
coming in could be rated r as well in
fact i think a lot of people want that
the original one was rated r because
well it did have some cursing in it but
it was also very violent as well but
let's think about this for a second it
really does seem like marvel studios is
about to open up an entirely different
side of the mcu here the perfect example
is doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness originally doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness was going to be
directed by scott derrickson he directed
the first doctor strange film which was
great and this one was supposed to be a
horror film now from what it sounds like
from what we've heard and this is not
officially confirmed because the studio
hasn't really said anything about this
but from what we heard scott derrickson
wanted to really go full out with a
horror film and kevin feige and marvel
kind of told him to tone it back just a
little bit there were some differences
and that's why he left the project but
then marvel studios hired sam raimi of
course we know him from directing the
original spider-man films but he's also
a horror movie director as well and
according to marvel studios this film
still is going to have several horror
aspects to it and this is really the
start along with what one division did
of introducing a more mystical magical
side of the mcu and with that sometimes
it can get pretty dark you can have dark
magic you could have possessions and we
already do have the darkhold book which
was made by an ancient evil elder god
c'thun and with all of these rumored
cameos that are supposed to happen in
multiverse of madness i'm thinking that
this is going to be the start of a
supernatural side of the marvel
cinematic universe also like i said we
have moon night coming we have blade
coming rumors of ghost rider and let's
not forget the marvel netflix series
might actually be kind of canon to the
mcu now which means the punisher could
be coming as well john bernthal has
expressed interest in coming back as the
punisher and he may be just a really
good actor and he could be lying and
they could have already told them yeah
you are coming back in one project or a
few projects or maybe a project of his
own but rumor has had it for a while
that the midnight suns are indeed going
to be coming in the mcu and with
everybody i just mentioned that would be
a pretty killer midnight suns team and
hopefully by the end of multiverse of
madness one doctor strange is alive and
two scarlet witch becomes good again
because that midnight sun's team could
be doctor strange the scarlet witch the
punisher moon knight ghost rider and
blade that would be a pretty awesome
team and i think deadpool would make a
great addition to that team as well i'm
just not so sure he would join the team
and like i mentioned in the beginning of
the video i think it would be really
really cool to see a team like this the
midnight suns interact with a team like
the avengers because you have to imagine
that somebody like the punisher and
somebody like deadpool going around
killing people that's not a good look
for superheroes and that look could
affect the avengers because they'll
probably associate with each other and
there's a lot that i'd actually like to
see from this one i would love to see
the banter between deadpool and some
really good heroes like clean cut heroes
like can you imagine deadpool having a
conversation with captain america either
captain america steve rogers or sam
wilson or imagine deadpool talking to
somebody like captain marvel there are
so many jokes that they could pull off
there especially since deadpool can
break the fourth wall i'd actually
really love to see loki and deadpool
have a conversation i think that would
be a pretty witty conversation but i can
even see the new avengers team stepping
in at some point in time to stop a team
like the midnight suns from going and
doing something and the two teams
fighting each other kind of like a civil
war and not to mention it does still
look like a team like the thunderbolts
or the dark avengers is being assembled
in the mcu as well they're not going to
be so good this will definitely add to
the darker side of the mcu although i
don't think that a team like the
thunderbolts or the dark avengers will
be rated r but there is so much
potential to marvel studios in disney
opening up this more r-rated side of the
mcu potential for it to get a lot
grittier a lot funnier and just bigger
and more diverse in general but let me
know what you think i know many people
who watch my channel have watched the
netflix series and really like them is
an r-rated side of the mcu something
that you would like to see or not let me
know don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof